the pandemic means holiday trips to the
movies are out for many americans but
don't worry
major releases like mahreni's black
bottom soul
and wonder woman 1984 will soon be
streaming right into our living rooms
elizabeth wagmeister
is the senior correspondent at variety
and she's got some recommendations to
keep us entertained in the weeks ahead
boy do i need this
elizabeth good morning thanks for being
with us good morning to you thanks for
having me
let's start with the prom which is a
musical comedy
uh with a huge lineup of stars led by
meryl streep uh it premieres friday on
netflix
it started as a stage play so how does
it compare
yes so this is based on the broadway
musical it comes from ryan murphy who is
the mastermind behind
glee and the politician and poe's
american horror story he directed this
for
netflix it's about a troupe of broadway
performers as you said
led by meryl streep also nicole kidman
kerry washington james corden
and they traveled to a conservative town
in indiana to help
a lesbian student bring her girlfriend
to the prom this is really
an upbeat film it's a musical it's all
about inclusivity it's exactly what we
need
during the holiday season and of course
has this huge a-list cast
i know you're right elizabeth i watched
the closing scene three times
james corden is great in it meryl streep
is rapping
they've got um andrew rammels in it it's
so
so good and it's just fun and it's full
of color and dancing and joy i love that
i want to talk to you about seoul i keep
hearing about this this animated film
starring jamie foxx and getting a lot of
buzz i'm very curious i really want to
see this what do you
what do you know about this one yes so
soul it is a pixar film and it was
originally set to be released
in theaters like every other film it was
supposed to be released in june well now
it is coming out on christmas
day on disney plus it is bypassing
theaters completely
it is just going to be streaming now it
is actually going to be streaming at no
additional cost
for disney plus subscribers yes it is if
you remember
mulan was on disney plus but for about
an additional
30 bucks they did it
and it seems that they heard that so
this will come with your subscription
if you are already a subscriber for
disney plus
one of the most anticipated action
movies of the year is a wonder woman
sequel wonder woman 1984
what can you tell us about that and also
can vlad duty get a poster because he
seems to like wonder woman a lot
according to his comments earlier this
morning
you know this film the first one it made
almost 900 million bucks at the box
office of course people
very excited for the sequel and this is
really going to serve as the litmus test
for where the industry is going because
it was supposed to be released in
theaters it was delayed numerous times
well now it's going to be
in theaters on december 25th christmas
day but also simultaneously
on hbo max so if theaters by you are
open if you feel safe to go you can see
it on the big screen
if not you could see it from the comfort
of your own home
also comes free with that hbo max
subscription which is about
15 per month but a lot of people in the
industry are saying
is this where we're going to go are we
just going to be on our couches or can
we really preserve those movie theaters
that's going to be really interesting
uh one thing i'm really looking forward
to is ma rainey's black bottom which
starts by ella davis it's also of course
chadwick boseman's final film what are
we hearing about this one that's good
yes so this is getting oscar buzzfor
both viola davis and chad with bozeman
now viola davis she stars as ma rainey
the
first queen of blues she is getting rave
reviews now viola davis if you didn't
know she's in a very
elite club of actors where she has a
tony
an emmy and an oscar so if she was
nominated again she could get
her second oscar and by the way she is
the only black actor to hold that title
of having
the triple crown now chadwick boseman he
is also getting rave review this will be
his final performance very sadly but a
lot of critics saying it is the best
performance of his entire career
and he seems to be a shoe-in for the
lead actor nomination
if not the win it's so good i think
viola davis should
start looking for an oscar dress just
saying let's talk about reginald
yeah she's awesome in it regina king
directing her first movie i'm really
excited about this for her i think she's
so talented
what are people saying about one night
in miami
she is so talented both in front of the
camera and behind the camera now one
night in miami it is a fictionalized
tale
of the meeting of a ton of legends
malcolm x and muhammad ali they meet in
a hotel room
in miami in the 1960s as you said this
is regina king's
directorial debut she debuted this film
at the venice film festival she was the
first
black female director to ever be at that
festival and if she gets the nomination
for best director
she'd be the first black female to get
an oscar nomination in the directing
category
wow all right a lot of hours team regina
right here
a lot of hours of my holiday have been
filled in this segment thank you
elizabeth we appreciate it